uh yes okay great awesome um
thank you lee hong and mark for the
invitation and for this wonderful
workshop
um so today i'll be talking about
exploiting latent structure and by
simulation metrics
for better generalization sorry sorry
this looks like the presenter view oh
yeah it's not the right okay
maybe you should let me try again
but this one yeah they work okay good
awesome well you got a sneak peek of my
next slide
um so this talk is mainly based on this
paper on learning invariant
representations for rl without
reconstruction
um and this is joint work with rowan
mcallister um
roberto calandra yaringal and sergey
levin
uh so the this work is is pretty similar
elisa
is focusing on a similar problem to the
talk that claire gave
um this was some follow-up work that
focused
more on the state abstraction setting
and and thinking about how we can sort
of like improve on the methods that we
use for
for learning those state abstractions um
and i just want to first start out with
uh like a more low-level view
at markup decision processes so this is
just you know
the definition of an mdp taken straight
from wikipedia
um and the thing that i want to
highlight is that this is
a very broad definition that doesn't
really take into account a lot of
the structure and additional assumptions
and inductive biases that we can put in
specifically about the real world um and
so i think the
important question to ask here is um
what kind of additional structure is
reasonable to assume in mdps because
you know with there's no free lunch like
we have to assume some kind of structure
in order to get good generalization
um and so in the in the setting that we
are looking at we assume
a setting where the agent sees like a
markovian high dimensional observation
which is rendered from some true latent
state and this is a very common
uh more very reasonable assumption to
make as this is a very common setting
for robotics as
rgb cameras are a really cheap way to
collect a lot of information about the
environment
um so in this figure here we can see
sort of like a breakdown of what
information in a pixel observation is
relevant versus irrelevant
so here if we have like an autonomous
driving task
if the car is in the same position on
the road and
and the road is basically the same shape
and leading to the same location
then what you see in the background or
what you see on the side of the road
isn't going to really affect your
dynamics or your reward and so you can
think of this as a relevant
information that we want to abstract
away
whereas like if you have another image
um shown in orange here where
you know the the road shape is different
but everything else looks the same
even if that irrelevant information
looks very similar in terms of its its
pixel distance um this clearly
corresponds to a different state in your
latent space
so it's important to think about like
how
far away these pixel observations are
in terms of their dynamics and reward as
opposed to their pixel distance
so our goal is to generalize to new
observations where the underlying mdp is
the same
and so what we want to do in order to
achieve this goal is to ignore relevant
information
um and so this is
this type of generalization or sort of
common sense generalization is something
that current rl algorithms can't do yet
and there's been a lot of prior work uh
in the last few years
mainly focusing on on looking at
empirical generalization results that
show that
if you incorporate small meaningless
changes in the observation space that
can cause policies to fail
so these are just some examples from
recent papers um that investigate
generalization in pixel space of dprl
methods
and in all of these cases there were
changes that were made between the
training and evaluation that
that humans can clearly generalize too
but so far deep rl algorithms cannot
um and so in order to solve this problem
this is now again like a a pretty
similar slide to what claire had and so
i'm really glad that claire
did such a good job at sort of
explaining and defining model irrelevant
state abstractions
because by simulation is is basically
the same thing um
by simulation relations are a type of
state abstraction that offers
like a mathematically precise definition
of what it means for two environments to
share the same structure
these are considered the strictest form
of state abstraction where no
information that affects
the transition behavior or reward is
lost
and so this is just the formal
definition of a bisimulation relation
which
um has this recursive property that just
checks that
under every action in your action space
that
uh that basically two states s1 and s2
are by similar if their reward is the
same
and their transition distributions to to
next latent states is the same
um so this this you know this state
abstraction definition is really nice
and we've seen from claire that
that we can get sort of like a very nice
generalization guarantees
from this definition um but exact
partitioning with by simulation
relations is
generally pretty impractical for
continuous state spaces because the
relation is very sensitive
to small changes in the reward function
or dynamics
so if if your reward differs or your or
your
transition distribution differs even by
a small amount then we can't say that
these two states are very similar
anymore
but how similar they are is still
important to us right like we we do
still want to
have a distinction between states that
are are more similar than others
um and so by simulation metrics
are are really nice because it basically
softens this concept of state partitions
and instead defines a pseudometric space
where a distance function measures the
behavioral similarity between two states
so in this definition f basically
defines this
iterative procedure that starts from all
states being mapped to the same point
and slowly uh separates states
based on um the computing this distance
between abstract states
um and so at the end of this this
iterative procedure basically f has
a unique fixed point which is our
bisimulation metric
for basically any value of c
um the problem with this definition is
that
this metric is really difficult to learn
because of its inherent pessimism
because it's basically considering
equivalence under all possible actions
so we have this
max over actions um which is very
difficult to
learn in practice so
we want to modify the previous
definition to get rid of this max
and make this uh this definition more
useful for control
um because in control we only care about
the the
the behavior of states under the optimal
policy
so we can modify the standard definition
to be specific to a policy pi
and we can show that if pi is
continuously improving
like under under policy iteration then
this iterative procedure also has a
phase point
which is our optimal policy by
simulation metric
so another issue is that this requires
that we have access to
the generative model like of of the
actual
um next state distribution um
under our ndp and so we can get around
this by just
learning a generative model of of of the
environment
um but computing the empirical
vasculstine of a generative model is
also difficult
um fortunately there are closed form
solutions
uh for gaussian distributions um
and the nice thing here is that because
we are learning
a latent dynamics model we can just
we can just add another sort of
assumption or restriction
that this model has to be gaussian which
means that we can now
we can now use this closed form
so now this leads us to our
representation learning objective
we want to learn a representation where
l1 distance between any two states in
that representation
is a measure of thereby similarity and
so we can do that with
this objective here so in blue we have
you know the l1 distance in this latent
space
and in red is is is the definition of
the bystander
by similarity between those two states
um and so we can plug this in directly
into a dprl algorithm and so we call our
method
deep by simulation for control or dbc
for short
um and here we're just using soft doctor
critic but it can be combined with any
rl optimization algorithm
so what we do is we sample transition
the batches of transitions from the
replay buffer
we train a reward model and dynamics
model uh
in in a latent space we
make a copy of that batch randomly
permute
those samples and so now we have uh
randomly selected pairs of states with
which
we can update uh we can train our
encoder with the previous objective
and update our representation space and
then in the next step
we just train our policy on top of this
latent representation so we just train
soft after critic on top
so to test out our our algorithm um
a lot of our empirical results are are
just using the deepmind control suite so
here uh we just have three example tasks
um fingerspin half cheetah and walker
walk and so
um these examples are just the original
rich observation um settings like from
deepmind control
but we modify this uh to add additional
visual complexity in the background so
now this
allows us to have many possible rich
observations that are mapping to the
same latent state
and we know here that the latent state
just corresponds to like the actual
proprioceptive state of the agent
um so we have this slightly more
difficult setting where we just have
symbol distractors which are these
just bouncing balls in the background
that don't interact with the agent
and then we have a third final most
difficult setting which is
using natural video so here we're just
using the kinetics data set from
deepmind
we use simple image processing
techniques to abstract away the
background
and replace it with uh with video frames
um so before i get to like you know the
the sort of like results
um i just want to show some qualitative
results
so here is a t-sne embedding for walker
walk in our natural video setting
and uh the color code here is is just
just the predicted value from the critic
um and so we can see that that states
with similar value are getting
grouped together um but another more
interesting thing
is that if you take two random data
points
that are near each other in this latent
space representation
um we see that the agent position
is almost identical um even though the
pixel distance between these
observations can be very different
because the background is completely
different
um in comparison if we look at
a t-sne of the same observations but
trained
uh with a latent representation trained
with the vae
we see that those same data points um
no longer map close together so the vae
basically
has is completely ignoring sort of the
um the the relevant information here
which is just the agent position
so if we look at um so here on the
on the left we also have just videos of
the
um of the policies trained with soft
vector critic
with our method um and we compare
against a bunch of different baselines
so
in orange we have a reconstruction based
method method so
this is using a pixel wise loss so we're
not losing any information about the
background
um we also compare against contrastive
loss
and uh there's been a lot of recent work
in this area
which is nice because it no longer has
this like
the it it doesn't force that you um
save all of the information in the rich
observation but what it does do
is it it saves all information that that
uh
that um that differs between two
observations so even if you have two
different observations that are of
what is the same um underlying state
then a contrastive loss is going to
force those to uh have different latent
states
um we also compare against a recent
state-of-the-art method
deep mdp and stochastic latent nectar
critic
so in the in the baseline setting we see
that these methods generally perform
quite well
especially slack but as we
increase the visual complexity of the
rich observation
we see that other methods that use
reconstruction
or contrastive methods all start to
show worse performance whereas dbc our
method
basically has consistent performance
across all
um all settings
uh so this is just the results from sort
of like
base case generalization or not even
generalization just sort of like
performance in the single task setting
across like very complex rich
observations
spaces um another nice
thing that we can get out of
these types of state abstractions is is
uh
expected generalization to new
observations and rewards
so as claire already pointed out um a
bi-simulation partition or model
irrelevant state abstraction
is equivalent to learning the causal
feature set
um of this mdp and so
what this means is that if we partition
these observations using the by
simulation metric
those clusters correspond to the um to
the causal feature set and therefore
at least in the linear setting we know
that we can generalize
to uh to like those irrelevant variables
taking on any other value
um we don't have those kinds of
guarantees for
non-linear function approximation but
we'll show empirically that
we do get some nice performance um
another thing is uh we can is
is the type of task generalization that
we can expect to see
so um we
also know that the causal feature set
consists of all of the causal ancestors
of the reward function
so what this means is that with this
representation that we've learned
we should also be able to generalize to
new tasks
as long as they consist of a subset of
the same
causal ancestors and so we'll see what
that looks like in
in sort of the next set of experiments
um
so first we look at the generalization
to new observations
um so in this experiment we take our
method and we train
first in the ideal gas environment
we freeze the representation and then
train soft director critic with that
frozen representation
using the natural video setting and so
we see
as a comparison that that transfer
actually performs slightly
better than dbc being trained on
trained and evaluated on the kinetics
data set
and then as as sort of like another
baseline we also look at deep mdp
um with the same kind of transfer
scenario where we transfer from ideal
gas to kinetics
and we see that our our method basically
um
performs best so
for generalization to new reward
functions so the limitation that we have
here
again is that this is only going to work
if the reward function has the same
causal ancestors
and so what this means is if you have an
agent that's
learned to pick up um say like like
spheres or orbs
um then it's going to abstract away
anything that is not
any objects that are not a sphere or
which won't give it reward
so if you try to use that representation
and train an agent to pick up cubes
instead
then um we know that it's it's not going
to be able to do that
but in deep end control we there are
access
to different reward functions that are
quite similar so specifically
uh with the walker agent
um there's there's three different
reward functions that we can look at
there's
walker stand walk and run and so
here we found that if you train dbc on
walker walk
that we can successfully generalize uh
to
stand and run and so these two plots are
just for stand and run and we can see
that if you just train
software to critic from scratch on the
pixel observation
um it performs much worse but a
soft director critic trained on a frozen
representation
from dbc is able to learn very quickly
um
and this is because the latent
representation that we learn has already
abstracted away
all of the complexity and the visual
space that that isn't
that does not cause reward
and so we see the same sort of same sort
of behavior in both stand and run
um so in the final set of experiments
that
i want to look at is just um
we want to show that these methods work
well for more realistic
rich observation settings like
autonomous driving so here we look at
carli which is a high fidelity
autonomous driving simulator where you
can pick different routes and
and change things in your rendering
in your rendering engine like the
weather conditions and time of day
in order to change the pixel
observations um
so the the task here is is
just highway progression in meters um
and
you know there's some a penalty for
colliding
uh with other with a wall or with other
cars
um and the goal is for the car to
is for the car to uh drive as quickly as
possible and use the brake as little as
possible
so in this setting we find that
we again compare with the same baselines
as we did in
deepmind control and again we see that
our method performs best and then we
also have some driving metrics
um in this table that basically show
more qualitative data
of how we perform income in comparison
to the baselines
um and so we have a significantly
higher number of trials which succeed
where the car is able to just progress
like 100 meters
without crashing um
it's able to progress on average many
more meters than soft factor critic or
deep mdp
and so you can there's also just other
numbers relating to crash intensity
average steering and and breaking
um and so here again i think it'll be
really nice to just see
what kind of pixel observations where
these pixel observations map to
like in the latent space so if we take a
look in
a high value section of this t-sne
what we see is really really interesting
because here you see that the
pixel observations all look completely
different they're even
sort of just like completely different
um
lighting conditions but the interesting
thing is
that in all of these in all of these
states
there is some obstruction on the right
hand side
and those obstructions are completely
different but they affect
the agent's policy in the same way which
is that it you know it can't change
lanes to the right otherwise it'll
collide with something
um the uh
similar points sort of like in like low
value states
are less interesting but they um
um you know usually the low value states
are are ones where they've already
crashed
um but we see here on the right hand
side
that again this is all just sort of open
road and so the policy kind of treats
all of these states is the same
um so here are just some additional
videos looking at what the latent space
looks like in carla as well as
the dbc agent point of view during an
episode
the nice thing that i really wanted to
point out on the left hand side is that
we have these three different weather
conditions
for the agent that are sunny cloudy and
sunset and so these are the exact same
episode
exact same initial state um and policy
but under very different yeah under
these different weather conditions and
you can see that
where they map to in the latent space is
it's not perfect but
at least they're they are mapping very
close together
um so to conclude the goal was to learn
lossy representations that only capture
relevant information and we can do this
by learning a representation where the
l1 distance is
by similarity between states and the
nice thing about using this objective
is also that we guarantee that we're
learning the coarsest partition
um we're we're learning the courses by
simulation partition because any two
states that are by similar
will are forced to to map to the same
latent state
um and we also show that policy
optimization on this representation
improves generalization
uh so thank you for listening to my talk
and i'm happy to answer any questions
excellent thanks amy
we have a few questions on a few minutes
for questions before we uh
move on to the next part um
so maybe i can uh start there's a
a slide in the top that i i may miss uh
the details
um i remember at some point i mean you
said that
you add some background image or video
to the control problem
um is it a static image or is it a video
um yeah so it's actually
video i can just start okay yeah so
um so like these videos are
examples like of the environments that
the agents are in so you can see in the
simple distractors that the balls are
just sort of slowly moving around in the
background
and in the bottom case um we're actually
taking
youtube videos so these are our natural
videos that um
and and like putting the frames uh
under each time step of the
of the demand control environment i see
i see i was i was thinking that it was a
static image then
there might be easier approach to
identify the
discover the right of the information
but yeah this is more interesting if you
have a video in the background
yeah so this is very similar to uh
if you remember the graphical model that
claire showed in her talk
um where you can think of the
the rich observation as being decomposed
into these two components like the
the relevant state that that uh that
causes the reward and the irrelevant one
and if you remember from her graphical
model
you can have arrows like causal arrows
from like the previous irrelevant state
to the current one and so you can think
of um
like this video setting as as following
as
uh sort of prescribing to that graphical
model
right how expensive is this to
to run the algorithm to discover
yeah it's actually a lot so it's on par
with other model based
or with other methods that learn a
dynamics model
um so i guess like yeah so i guess here
we have like the bass lines that we used
so it's a lot cheaper than stochastic
latent actor critic
um and the reconstruction based method
because these methods are using pixel
wise losses
so they have to have like very large
decoders that map
back to the original pixel space and and
compute that loss
whereas our method only needs to do this
in the latent space so you only really
depend on
on the dimensionality of your latent
space um and so for these experiments
like our latent space was just
50 dimensional so it's it's quite small
i see but what is the cost for you to
get the latent space
before you run it before you use it um
so in practice
um we actually uh we
we train both things sort of like end to
end uh
together so every time step that the
agent takes in the environment
um both we sort of uh this entire stack
of things runs so we um
like after we've collected enough data
in the environment to populate the
replay buffer then we
select a batch um we train the inc we
train the dynamics reward model and
representation space using our by uh by
simulation metric objective
and then train soft tractor critic on
top of it so
um like again it's it's
basically very similar to other methods
like deep mdp and stochastic latent
nectar critic
in that um you just have all of these
components that are trained
at every uh after
every environment step um
so yeah so i would say it's like on par
with those
right right cool
it yeah so this is cool and uh
um it seems the problem is you have a
nice solution to this problem
um could you say something about open
problem what is
what could be next steps yeah so the
downside
of of by simulation by simulation
metrics is that it's very tied to
just a single reward function right or
like you're determining what is
relevant and irrelevant um using the
reward
only um so
this isn't going to work well for
like uh like say a family of tasks where
you have
many different reward functions um it's
a little bit unclear how you can sort of
extend this to that scenario um
a couple things that we're thinking
about are
doing conditional by simulation so this
actually maps back to
um jacob's talk this morning
where like we can use natural language
to define this like family of tasks
and you can learn like a like a
conditional
um encoder that takes in the natural
language
uh command and outputs like a
representation space specific for that
task
and that way this encoder can sort of
can contain information for this entire
family of tasks but
but each representation is still going
to be specific to one
um another thing is is
especially for like rich observation
robotics
um reinforcement learning might not be
the best approach
uh and and it might be that we actually
want something more similar to like
imitation learning or combination of
imitation learning and reinforcement
learning
um and so we're thinking about how we
can take this
this definition of by simulation and
adapt it to the imitation learning
setting
so now instead of instead of having
access to reward that we can use to
define if two states are by similar or
not
instead uh we can take um
[Music]
expert trajectories or or uh yeah like
example trajectories and use those to
determine
like if two states should be considered
uh like the same under some
some definition cool
yeah thanks um yeah
awesome so um if we don't have uh
further questions
um perhaps it's time to um to have a
break uh to recover from the
zoo meetings um and then in 30 minutes
uh we'll come back
uh we'll have two more talks uh one from
doing a breakup the other from kakade
yeah thanks again to all the free
speakers this morning and i'll see you
back in 30 minutes thanks